you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's
programme
germany goes to the polls to elect its
first new chancellor for 16 years but
just how green will the country be post
merkel
a change of direction barred from
blocking the m25 insulate britain
climate protesters turn their attention
to dover
and why the uk's mosques haven't just
issued a call to prayer today but also a
call for climate action
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions now germans will vote this
sunday in elections that will see angela
merkel's 16-year reign as chancellor
come to an end
climate change has played heavily in the
election campaign at one point the green
party was even leading the polls it's
now slipped to third place but the
results could still see it become part
of a coalition government
so let's have a look at just how green
or otherwise germany is so the country
is europe's biggest emitter of carbon
dioxide and its energy mix is still
heavily reliant on fossil fuels in 2019
about 77 of germany's energy came from
fossil fuels that compares to just 22
percent of energy from renewables
just five percent of the country's
energy comes from nuclear compared to
about 36 percent in neighboring france
this is partly because since 1998
germany has been phasing out nuclear
energy which has always been unpopular
after the 2011 fukushima disaster it
immediately shut down eight of its 17
reactors and plans to shut all of its
plants by next year
in june germany adopted an amendment to
its climate law together with an 8
billion euro climate emergency program
following a constitutional court ruling
that its climate targets were too weak
and put future generations in danger
but even with the amendment germany
scheduled 2038 coal phase-out is
incompatible with the 1.5 degree warming
limit of the paris agreement well our
europe correspondent adam parsons is in
munich this evening adam just how much
has climate featured in the campaigning
in the run-up to this weekend's
elections
it's a significant factor uh for about
20-25 of voters it is the number one
thing there's no doubt that it's playing
a big part in this election the reason
we're in munich is just round the corner
from us
we have a conference center where the
cdu that is angela merkel's party uh
have been holding one of their last
rallies armin laschette the contender
for them
is there along with all the the great
and the good from the cdu but they are
trailing uh in the polls at the moment
going to these final days and climate is
one of the reasons the green party is
polling better than it has done
in previous elections perhaps picking up
a bit on some of the anger after those
floods that we had uh just a few months
ago they haven't had the pickup they
might expect but certainly for younger
voters particularly i think it's
important big protests across germany
today including in berlin where the
crowd was addressed by gretenberg here's
what she told them
we must vote you must vote
but remember that voting only will not
be enough
we must keep going into the streets and
we must keep demanding our leaders to
take real climate action
uh of course greta timberlake is swedish
you won't be voting on this but over 60
million people will now at the moment
the predictions are that yet again
germany will have a coalition
how that looks we simply don't know and
it takes potentially weeks maybe even
months to put that coalition together
the merkel reign could continue one
person told us today they thought it
might go up until christmas it will be
down to annalina bearbot the leader of
the greens to play her cards correctly
one analyst telling me that actually he
thinks that she may have a stronger
position to force a climate agenda if
she's part of a coalition
rather than the chancellor
adam thank you
and we're going to be discussing whether
climate change is a key issue for german
voters on today's debate i'm going to be
joined by the economist vicki price and
professor of global change science at
ucl and the university of leeds simon
lewis
that's in a few minutes time
now after blocking sections of the m25
five times in the past fortnight
insulate britain protesters were banned
by the high court this week from
blocking the motorway and threatened
with prison by the transport secretary
grant shaps so today members of the
extinction rebellion offshoot changed
tack and headed for dover where 39
people were arrested after blocking the
entrance to the port skies aisha zahed
was there
insulate britain have been protesting in
dover today around 40 protesters
blocking off access to the port of dover
the a2 and a third group blocking a part
of the a20 and not only have they
disrupted roads today but also channel
crossings now we saw similar tactics
being used as we have seen in their
previous protests hands being glued to
the road and two activists also mounted
a tanker it took nearly five hours to
get them off understandably there were
lots and lots of frustrated and angry
motorists on the road and the
government's also come back and said
that they are taking action against
these guerrilla tactics being used to
prevent them from happening in the
future now insulate britain are
demanding that the government does more
to make homes more energy efficient to
help tackle climate change they've
protested on the m25 five times the
government's been granted an injunction
against them for this they've also held
demonstrations on the m3 and m11 more
than 200 arrests made so far and it's
not stopping them they say they're not
scared of being arrested they're not
scared of government injunctions what
they are fearful of is climate change
now in some of today's other climate
news big businesses including bt thames
water and the co-op have called on the
government to phase out gas power by
2035. in a letter shared exclusively
with sky news the business told
ministers the time's right for the uk to
signal an end to the use of unabated
fossil fuels
sustainability told us it was all
important in the light of recent price
hikes
well we've seen the rising cost of
importing gas is pushing up prices for
both businesses and consumers and this
trend is set to continue so the best way
for us to guarantee energy security in
the uk is by generating our own
electricity from clean sources and of
course this can play a massive role in
tackling climate change
half a million acres of the scottish
highlands are to be re-wilded as part of
efforts to restore nature the 30-year
project will increase connected habitats
and species diversity across the africa
highlands the scenario between the west
coast of scotland and loch ness plans
include planting trees enhancing river
corridors restoring peat bogs and
creating nature-friendly farming
practices
homeowners affected by flooding are
spending an average of 5
250 pounds each year to protect and
repair their homes according to research
from the climate coalition homeowners
living on flood plains are also paying
more for contents insurance the
environment agency estimates that 5.2
million properties in the uk are
currently at risk of flooding and
climate change could cause that number
to double in the next 50 years
now hundreds of mosques across the uk
didn't just issue a call for prayer
today they also used their friday
sermons to call for action on climate
change the message was organized by the
muslim charities forum as part of the
big green week
sadia chaudhary has this report
zeki ismael is a farm shop owner who
doesn't like to give his customers much
choice
chicken duck turkey it doesn't matter
what you go for here you have to choose
ethical
when we're looking at thai it's
something that's pure it's natural it's
ethical
it's it's a natural way of raising
livestock and it's a clean and
it's an it's a product that's clean and
it not just with meat also with fruit
and vegetables
and anything else that we would consume
or anything else that we would tend to
do in our lives
the search for ethical farming led zeki
to this farm in seven oaks where animals
are grass-fed
muslims eat above average quantities of
meat which explains why the halal market
is one of the fastest growing in the
uk's meat industry
but many focus only on halal forgetting
that ethical or teib is just as
important a more islamic diet muslim
communities could have a big impact on
how we tackle climate change on british
farms
eat those foods that are halal and that
are also pure for you as well
today at friday prayers across the
country a reminder that fussy eaters
will go to heaven
300 mosques are putting climate change
at the heart of their sermons and it's
not just about making better dietary
choices but also things like switching
to renewable energy and reducing how
much we consume
the imam is using early islamic
traditions to try and win over his
audience
at aliman center in bromley imam
abdullah explains why addressing climate
change is central to islam islamically
you know we believe that god created the
universe god created the earth and he
has placed us in this planet on this
earth as custodians or caretakers
meaning that as humankind we have to
take care of ourselves take care of
other humankind also take care of the
plant life take care of the animals and
the environment
muslims are being reminded to make more
ethical more islamic choices and the
message is clear
protect the world you live in and that
could be what gets you to heaven once
you've left
sadia chowdhury sky news
do stay with us because coming up after
the break
i'm going to be joined by the economist
vicky price and professor of global
change science climate lewis and we're
going to be discussing if germany is a
climate change leader and whether it's
realistic for the uk to phase out gas
power by 2035
the weather stays fairly quiet and warm
over the weekend we could see daytime
highs up to around 24 even 25 degrees
celsius there's a good deal of dry
weather around too but also large
amounts of cloud at times early mist and
fog in the south and later on we'll see
some
more persistent rain working its way in
towards the northwest although it'll be
sunday before it comes through
so a largely fine day top temperatures
again around 24 even 25 degrees celsius
fairly breezy with strong winds in the
north so air pollution levels will be
low
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show here on sky news and we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day with the
economist vicki price and simon lewis
professor of global change science at
ucl and the university of leeds there
they are and we've been looking ahead of
sunday's german election that we'll see
the end of angela merkel's 16 years in
power at the country's green credentials
the climate has featured heavily in the
election campaign but is germany as
green as it would like to think simon
and vicky thank you so much for joining
us um simon let's start with you just
how green is germany
uh germany's not that green in that
about a quarter of its electricity is
coming from coal-fired power stations
very polluting and it's coming from the
worst kind of coal lignite
and it doesn't have a phase-out until
2038
and to put that in context
uh xi jinping the chinese leader
announced that the un
that it would phase out
all overseas financing of coal-fired
power stations and struck out 47
coal-fired power stations with that one
sentence
and that's about the same carbon
emission stopped as germany's emitting
with its coal-fired power stations today
and on cars it doesn't have any phase
out date
for phase it for ending the sale of new
petrol and diesel cars
and
without that
and with the coal
uh the the supreme court
in uh in germany uh said that germany's
climate policies were unconstitutional
because young people wouldn't have a
good life
in the future because
these policies were not committed that
were not
consistent with
the paris agreement
it's interesting isn't it a recent poll
found that 65 of germans are in favor of
stricter measures to fight climate
change vicky what do you think it's
interesting that the the greens are in
third place you'd think
with that sort of public support they'd
be right up there in first wouldn't you
you would indeed but of course we must
remember that uh germany is a major
manufacturing country
uh it has a much larger percentage of
manufacturing is gdp than is the case in
the uk so phasing out all that because
lots of energy-intensive sectors there
which we find it difficult to move to
uh you know
using
cleaner energy
uh because basically not much cleaner
energy is necessarily supplied and what
is going on right now of course is that
germany is relying heavily on gas that
comes out of uh russia it has said it's
going to stop any new nuclear and of
course that's been phased out so it's
limited in terms of what you can
actually do but i think on the positive
side
we need to bear in mind that it's very
much part of the push right now that the
eu is making in terms of clean uh green
bonds
raising money that can be spent in more
energy efficient
uh production and of course it's also
moving way ahead of other countries in
battery production so there is still a
lot that is happening the question is
how fast can they move to meet where the
population was but as you say
interestingly the greens are not doing
uh as well as perhaps you would have
expected which suggests to me that uh
the germans still value quite a lot of
what is being produced right now by the
by the industry there that existed
present
um simon let's go back to this court
ruling that you mentioned april 2021 a
court ruled that germany's climate
change laws are insufficient again it
looks like all the right noises are
being made angela merkel herself was a
supporter of climate protection measures
do you think we are going to see a
change after these elections that
change will actually take place and it
won't just be talk
well i think it's it's uh it's going to
be difficult to say and that's because
the german uh electoral system is is
different from the uk and they will have
a coalition
um but if it's a coalition between some
of the left parties and the green party
then that probably gives the greatest
chance of really shifting policies
towards a much greener agenda whether
that's green homes
electric vehicles and getting uh their
electricity supply onto renewables as
fast as possible
okay well let's um let's leave the
germans well obviously we found out this
weekend how that election will play out
because we've also heard today that big
uk businesses including bt thames water
the co-op and nestle have called on the
government to phase out gas power by
2035 that's just 14 years away so is it
achievable um vicky what do you think 40
of the uk's electricity
generation comes from gas plants do you
think we can phase it out by 2035
i think it's going to be rather
difficult the reason why they're calling
for it of course
uh is because of the increase that we're
just seeing in gas prices there is a
belief that we don't have enough
security to supply and therefore we need
to move into something else now the
question is are they asking for this
because it's clean or are they asking
for this because they really want to
make sure that whatever power there is
comes easily to the very sectors that
need it and you know it could be a
combination of the two which
would be interesting but it costs a lot
to move from where we are now in terms
of using different type of fuel if you
like in those very heavy energy
intensive sectors like for example
steels and chemicals and cement where
the costs are
very very great in terms of moving into
something else and they use huge amount
of heat for the process of production
that they've got at present so it is
going to be difficult it will require
a lot more investment than what we've
got planned at present
um so what do you think given what we're
seeing at the moment um not having to
rely on gas imports it sounds like it
would be an excellent thing
uh yes it would be and uh i don't think
it's that much of a surprise that these
household names have called for it
because
the government's statutory body on uh
advising and among climate change the
committee on climate change actually
says that unabated gas should be over by
2035. so it's actually consistent with
what the messages that the government is
getting and what we are seeing
here is is a kind of a difference
between what the
most cost effective and the least
disruptive
way forward that the committee on
climate changes are laying out and the
policies that have been put in place and
not been put in place in a timely manner
to get us there and
i think on fossil fuels
there was a great report out last week
from oxford university that showed that
for fossil fuels
that are the costs that are adjusted for
inflation
they have not got any cheaper over the
last
140 years
whereas renewables have been decreasing
in price incredibly rapidly they are 2
000 times
cheaper today than they were
50 years ago so it makes sense to get
onto renewables
and off fossil fuels and vicky is
correct in that there are some
industrial processes that require uh
huge amounts of heat but carbon-free
production of steel has already started
in sweden and the uk needs to get at the
beginning of the head of that curve and
move to those green industries to get
those green jobs and a transition away
from these dirty heavy industries
towards green industries but vicky it it
does all come down to money doesn't it
getting there the lesser even says the
move would require a significantly
greater level of investment in
renewables that has been possible to
date and that's 14 billion pounds a year
who's going to foot that bill
well that's a very good point i think
what the government needs to do right
now
is to share the risk if you like with
the private sector there is a lot of
money around that can be invested in
green technology as we've seen you know
those that people are buying up uh
companies like there's no tomorrow and
they are prepared to support list of
governments who are trying to raise
money so there is a lot of liquidity
around that can be used uh properly uh
to support a cleaner economy though the
problem is that the risks involved with
technology are still very great so
governments and freight have to step in
like they're doing in the eu i think we
need to do that in the uk as well and
share that risk and give a sort of
guarantee to whoever may want to go down
that investment rate but without that i
think there would be a lot of reluctance
to engage in something which may just
lead to no results at all for individual
investors
okay vicky price simon lewis thank you
so much it's been fantastic talking to
you have a great weekend thank you
that's everything from us for this week
but do stay tuned because coming up next
on sky news tonight ministers hold
crisis talks on how the national
shortage of lorry drivers can be
resolved as queues at several petrol
stations continue to grow thanks for
watching see you next time
[Music]
you